well after weeks of rising infections
the Spanish government is also
expressing cautious optimism despite
more than 15,000 deaths the number of
daily fatalities has begun inching lower
but Spaniards will not be allowed to
leave their homes for at least another
two weeks and schools will remain closed
the measures are hitting children from
low-income families in particular Mata
buses most important tools right now are
her smartphone and laptop from her own
backyard she uses them to try to keep in
touch with her students but it's not
always possible Mia and his parents
don't have an internet connection at
home so until recently he was stuck
permanently offline a friend brought me
over a few homework assignments I can do
those but unfortunately I can't do the
other assignments because I need to be
online
[Applause]
the only reason Miguel is able to talk
with his teacher right now is because a
schoolmate gave him a prepaid SIM card
Marta says that was great but it's no
long-term solution I have students who
are really good but they can't continue
their learning it the government should
be making sure that everyone has access
to the Internet and all students have
the chance to take part in classes
online Spain has some of the highest
poverty levels in Europe especially
among minors according to the United
Nations 30% of all Spanish children and
adolescents are at risk of poverty
internet access is not much better
around one in five families in Spain
still don't have a computer at home
isolation social exclusion problems at
school children from low-income families
are especially affected by the crisis
and there's another direct risk
government reports have found that the
number of people infected in poorer
neighborhoods is up to seven times
higher than in rich districts there's a
lot of discussion in Spain about
possible reasons but what is already
clear is that a person's social status
plays a role in how much the virus
affects someone Marta stays positive but
the longer school's stay closed the
harder it will be for disadvantaged
students to catch up on their learning
Matta can't wait to leave her home
office and get back into a real
classroom again but many in Spain
believe that's unlikely to happen before
the summer holidays well young Philip
Schultz filed that report for us and he
joins us now from Seville Spain so as
we've heard there are a lot of
discussion about at the moment about
inequality and especially why poorer
people apparently are disproportionately
affected by this virus tell us more I
think there are many reasons that play a
role in this first of all it's about
living space in general Spain has very
little living space compared to other
countries in Europe living space per
person and this means that of course
little living space and a lot of people
in one apartment helps the spread of the
virus and this is especially true in
flora neighborhoods also it's a question
about education we're talking about a
lot of minority groups in those
neighborhoods that usually have lower
levels of formal education and also a
lot of distrust and messages of the
government and last but not least it's
also about the kind of jobs that many
people in those neighborhoods have if
you are a cleaner for example you can't
do home office and you are obviously
much more exposed to the virus meantime
you know we also have another set of
challenges because the Easter break is
traditionally a time especially there in
Spain when citizens they crisscross the
country there they're visiting family
how high is the concern that people will
ignore travel restrictions right now
so far Spaniards have been incredibly
disciplined when it comes to following
the rules of the lockdown so I don't
think that this will change now during
the holiday break there is a lot of fake
news out there about people trying to
need to reach their the holiday homes
and there's also pictures of congested
highways around Madrid Madrid is one of
the most affected areas the summer falls
on fertile grounds because in the first
days of the the crisis a lot of people
from Madrid have actually tried to leave
the city but police officers have said
that they have a lot of controls on the
streets and they haven't seen anything
unusual so far young Philip Schultz
joining us from Seville thank you
Europe's finance ministers have struck a
deal on a 500 billion euro bailout aimed
at limiting the economic damage from the
coronavirus the measures should help
nations hardest hit bykova 19 as well as
supporting companies and protecting jobs
the breakthrough came after ministers
failed to bridge their differences in
marathon talks earlier this week
southern European countries led by Italy
and Spain wanted the European Union to
ease access to financial markets by
creating so-called Corona bonds but the
idea was resisted by Richert northern
states including Germany the Netherlands
and Finland
let's get more we're joined by boundary
Gert who is following the story for us
from Brussels so bad tell us a little
bit more about what exactly is in this
very highly anticipated deal there was a
sigh of relief in all 27 capitals of the
European Union after the finance
ministers instructed this deal after two
days of very fierce deliberations and
they gave themselves a round of applaud
on this and Mario sentain of the
Portuguese Finance Minister the head of
the Euro group said these are bold and
ambitious decisions that were not
possible just a few weeks ago at the
German Finance Minister Olaf Shultz said
this is a good day for Europe and a good
day for solidarity the package contains
of three components first there come 200
billions of loans for small and medium
enterprises from the European Investment
Bank in Luxembourg 100 billion euros in
a new unemployment scheme and 240
billion euros of cheap loans from the
European Stability Mechanism a rescue
fund originally created of in the Greek
crisis and and these loans now now come
without any conditions and that
Netherlands caved in here and Italy one
said the Italian finance minister after
the deliberations altogether 540 billion
years the biggest package the union has
ever made and Italy and Spain date they
were among these countries needing the
most assistance very urgent for those
two nations did they get what they
wanted yes and no they get this
emergency funding but the bigger issue
is still to be resolved The ministers
agreed in principle on a new recovery
fund but did not agree how big this
should be to restart the European
economy diving into a recession and they
could also not agree how to finance this
recovery plan they are still Spain
France and Italy that say we have to
issue common debt to do that and on the
other side there are Germany in the
Netherlands and others that say no way
so the issue of
so-called Corona bonds is not resolved
ban triggered with a view from Brussels
where we have just had agreement on this
five hundred billion euro emergency
credit lines thank you so much
well Asian markets have largely shrugged
off that new EU a package as well as an
ambitious new lending program from the
US Federal Reserve Japan's leading
Nikkei index shed early gains to close
at a loss
Shanghai also lost ground on Friday
investors were buoyed though by gains on
Wall Street after the US central bank
announced it would lend directly to
businesses and local governments and
after agreement on that half trillion
euro rescue package but concerns over
the rising economic toll proved too much
German Chancellor Angela Merkel says
that she sees signs of hope in the fight
against Cova 19 social distancing is
helping to slow the spread of the
coronavirus in the country but Merkel
warrants now is not the time to ease the
lockdown deserted streets in the German
capital a common sight in countries
facing coronavirus around the world but
according to experts in Germany the
restrictions on movement seemed to be
having a positive effect the number of
new cases there appears to be leveling
out but with a long Easter weekend
looming German Chancellor has warned
against getting complacent we mustn't
allow ourselves to be lulled into a
false sense of security instead we
should be really happy that more
stringent measures aren't necessary for
me this means that we cannot be reckless
now we mustn't allow ourselves to be
lulled into this false sense of security
and I know that from myself personally
you get a little hope then you gain
confidence then you become a little more
relaxed and then you're a little
careless I know we have to stay focused
the situation is fragile
you Germany also announced plans on
Thursday to increase domestic production
of protective medical gear Asian
manufacturers are currently responsible
for 90 percent of the world's production
of protect
of masks more than 100 companies have
responded to the government's call for
help no success a game I went on
zangoose play as a result in our
discussions about procurement and the
purchase of personal protective
equipment especially medical protective
masks we saw the first steps of progress
some companies that operate here in
Germany are already investing in
increasing the production of the
material that's needed for masks it's
the University and signs of cautious
optimism in Germany but the debate over
an exit strategy to lift restrictions
will resume after Easter
let's get you up to date now on our
latest developments because John Hopkins
University is coronavirus tracking
website now shows that more than 1.6
million confirmed cases have been
recorded worldwide almost 96 thousand
people have died of kovin 19 Yemen's
internationally recognized government
has confirmed its first case widespread
poverty in five years of civil war make
the country especially vulnerable to a
severe outbreak and authorities in
Indonesia's capital Jakarta are
implementing stricter restrictions to
slow the spread of the virus
about half of confirmed cases are in the
capital Chicago's Cook County Jail is
reporting 450 inmates and staff have
tested positive the jail holds almost
5,000 prisoners and is now one of the
biggest clusters in the United States
all right now let's take a look at some
other coronavirus related news from
around the world Britain's Prime
Minister remains in intensive care and
Sir Thomas's Hospital in London for a
fourth day Boris Johnson's being treated
for covered 19 illness caused by the
corona virus a foreign secretary Dominic
Robb who's mr. Johnson's designated
deputy as says the Prime Minister is
making positive steps
well the pandemic has now killed at
least a hundred doctors in Italy
according to the country's national
doctors Federation the deaths include
some of the medics the gay tallien
government called out of retirement a
month ago it's also estimated that about
30 nursing staff have died from cough in
nineteen the International Monetary Fund
says the pandemic is causing the worst
economic fallout since the Great
depression of the 1930s more than 170
countries are expected to see a decline
in per capita income this year and
almost total a reversal of pre-pandemic
projections the emerging economies and
low-income nations will be the worst
affected the u.s. jobs market is
continuing its collapse last week saw
another 6.6 million people are filing
for unemployment benefits bringing the
total number to almost 70 million the
flood of new claims is so large that
some states including the state of
Florida has opened up a drive-through
unemployment offices so a grim outlook
then for the US economy earlier we asked
the head of a leading German economic
think tank what that means for the
global economy we have to understand
that the global economy is so integrated
so strongly integrated and the u.s. is
so important for everyone for all
European economies for China that if the
u.s. is not recovering the rest of the
world will not be covered so clearly
China is ahead of the curve is where you
see the businesses starting up again
production rising but the US probably
has not reached the peak yet so here we
are probably two months three months
behind what is happening in China so
this will mean until the u.s. is not
recovering markedly the world economy
will be in in a difficult situation
conservationists say restrictions
brought in to halt the spread of
coronavirus could prompt a resurgence in
poaching and other threats to wildlife
the pandemic has prompted Kenya to close
its national parks effectively ending
its ecotourism a key source of revenue
used to protect endangered species it's
breakfast time at the Sheldrick Wildlife
Trust near Nairobi the organization
calls itself the world's most successful
elephant orphan rescue program but now
it's work and it's animals face a new
threat we have closed our doors due to
copa90 the orphanage stopped admitting
visitors last month when Kenya recorded
its first coronavirus infection
can have up to 500 people here in just
an hour so that's an incredible source
of revenue for us for our operations
that we aren't seeing come in at the
moment normally at this time they'll be
out for the public session which is no
longer taking place until further notice
and that's why we just let them out and
let them do what they want to do brows
play and enjoy the orphanage has also
been forced to shut down other important
operations including its airborne
anti-poaching patrols many of the
animals in its care saw their parents
killed by poachers hunting their
valuable tusks we don't want to die we
don't want them to die so we just have
to work within our means and ensure that
everybody is safe and that animals are
safe as well but with no money coming in
and the eyes of the world focused on
kovat nineteen's impact on humans it's
becoming harder to look after africa's
endangered animals for the world's
biggest religions the coming days are
usually filled with celebrations
Christians mark Easter Jews mark
Passover and for Muslims the fasting
period of Ramadan begins later this
month but the need for social distancing
means religious leaders have scaled back
or canceled many traditional public
festivals and celebrations Easter at the
Vatican this is what Catholics around
the world expect every year tens of
thousands packing st. Peter's Square as
Pope Francis addresses the faithful what
will it look like this year the Pope
will say Mass in an empty Basilica and
his address from his balcony has been
canceled worshippers must stay home
highways across Europe like here in
Germany are usually clogged on Easter
weekend as people voyage cross country
to visit family but this year lockdown
measures also mean people can't leave
their home towns or cities in many
places
in Israel the eight-day Jewish festival
of Passover is marked by public prayers
and big meals with extended family but
this year travel is banned and
observances must take place at home and
are restricted to close family
soldiers are delivering sealed meals to
people in isolation for Muslims Ramadan
said to start in two weeks is a month of
fasting that ends with a celebratory
feast but religious leaders have said
that people with fragile health should
not fast this year and several countries
have even closed mosques altogether too
many of the faithful these restrictions
are heartbreaking but authorities fear
that allowing traditional large-scale
celebrations to go ahead could undo
weeks of lockdown
[Music]